The end of A Series of Unfortunate Events
is finally here and, after three seasons of
very fascinating drama, we now have answers
to many questions fans have been dying to
know.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining all the mysteries
from the last season of Unfortunate Events
including the Sugar Bowl, VFD, the fate of
the Baudelaires and Count Olaf, and who Beatrice
really is.
Keep watching to the end where I'll reveal
the final episode's secret symbolism and watch
out for the hidden VFD I've snuck into the
video.
Spoilers ahead for the full series, so take
care if you're not up-to-date.
One of the biggest mysteries in the series
has been the Sugar Bowl and why everyone is
so obsessed with getting hold of it.
The secret is revealed in the very final episode
when Kit explains to the Baudelaires that
the bowl simply contains sugar.
However, it's no ordinary sugar – it's a
sugar derived from a botanical hybrid that
VFD developed to defend against the deadly
Medusoid Mycelium.
Which is why during the opera flashback, after
Esmé adds sugar from the sugar bowl to Kit's
tea, she tells her that she'll find the sugar
is extremely bitter, however, Kit never drank
the tea, sadly for her given her eventual
fate.
Crucially, Kit also reveals to the Baudelaires
on the island that the hybrid sugar isn't
just a cure, it actually immunises you against
the Medusoid Mycelium.
Remember when Sunny is infected with the deadly
spores from the mushroom in the Grotto, well,
the horseradish substitute, wasabi, that the
Baudelaires use to cure her works, but it's
just an antidote, not a vaccine and so Sunny
gets infected again on the island.
In the TV series, the Medusoid Mycelium is
introduced in Season 3's The Grim Grotto episodes
where it's revealed that Gregor Anwhistle
was cultivating a disease that could annihilate
VFD's enemies.
The Hook-Handed Man, aka Fernald, warned him
that the weapon he was developing was too
dangerous and risky as it could wipe out everyone.
However, Gregor wouldn't listen; so, Fernald
burned down the laboratory which effectively
ended up isolating the Mycelium there.
The botanical hybrid vaccine in the sugar
bowl was recreated by the Baudelaire's parents
when they were stranded on the island.
The children discover this while searching
for a cure after they get infected.
The solution lies in a tree their parents
grew which contains the vaccine, so when they
eat an apple from the tree, they're cured.
Interestingly, the snake that gives them the
apple in this scene is the same Incredibly
Deadly Viper from Uncle Montgomery's collection
that was falsely accused by Olaf of killing
Uncle Monty.
By the end of the series, the power of the
Sugar Bowl's contents is clear, especially
if a villain were to have both that and the
biological weapon that is the Medusoid Mycelium.
The Sugar Bowl is also one of the factors
that triggers the Schism within VFD.
In the opera flashback, Esmé and Beatrice
argue over who should keep the valuable sugar
vaccine safe.
Beatrice knows there are already tensions
within the VFD organisation, with some parties
arguing they don't want to put out fires,
and warns Esmé about the Woman With Hair
But No Beard and the Man With A Beard But
No Hair.
But Esmé insists on keeping the sugar bowl
herself, as it completes her tea set.
So, Beatrice and Lemony conspire to steal
it.
In their words, "it's a wicked thing to do
for a noble reason."
That phrase, in fact, is a recurrent theme
throughout the final season as the lines between
right and wrong become blurred and the Baudelaires
themselves question whether, at times, they
really acted in a moral way.
In fact, much of this season deals with the
idea of moral ambiguity or moral relativism.
"Is a personal philosophy of moral relativism
the only way to survive in an ethically complex
world, or is it an excuse we use to justify
doing bad things?"
Of course, Beatrice and Lemony's heist ends
up causing an incident that leads to a series
of unfortunate events.
When Esmé discovers their plot, she faces
off against them, but Olaf's father steps
in the way and ends up dead from a poisoned
dart that Beatrice intended for Esmé.
Lemony takes the fall for Beatrice because
he's in love with her, and he escapes with
the Sugar Bowl in a taxi, leaving Beatrice
behind, and that's why he's on the lam during
the series.
Olaf vows that Beatrice will burn, which gives
us the best evidence yet that he set the fire
that burned down the Baudelaire mansion, killing
their parents, even though he later casts
doubt on that before he dies on the island.
Lemony's love for Beatrice also explains why
the narrator of the series is so interested
in the fate of her children and why it's a
bittersweet moment for him when he meets his
niece Beatrice in the final scene.
The last part of Chapter 14, which serves
as an epilogue to the series, takes place
many years later, probably at least a decade
after the events of the island.
In the epilogue, Lemony Snicket comes face-to-face
with Beatrice Baudelaire (the Second).
She's the daughter that his sister Kit gave
birth to on the island and who the Baudelaires
raised there for a year before setting sail.
The addition of this final chapter is a nice
nod to the final book from the Unfortunate
Events series and, as it's the 14th chapter,
it takes the story beyond the unlucky number
13, suggesting that the Baudelaires' long
streak of bad luck may finally have been broken.
We can see that Lemony's niece Beatrice survived
and made it back to the mainland at some point,
however, the fact she doesn't appear to be
with the Baudelaires any longer suggests they
were separated some time through the years.
In fact, there are some interesting teases
in what the young Beatrice tells us:
"Female Finnish pirates"
"It was after we sailed away from the island
but before their third trip to Briny Beach,
Violet had just tied up her hair to invent
the steering mechanism and Klaus was studying
tidal charts."
The "female Finnish pirates" that Beatrice
mentions suggest that after leaving the island
on the boat, the children encountered some
seaborne bandits.
And the mention is also a nice easter egg
to the knot that Violet uses in the second
episode of season 2:
"This knot's called the Devil's Tongue."
"It was invented by female Finnish pirates
in the 15th century."
The children evidently survived the pirate
encounter because Beatrice says that that
happened before "their third trip to Briny
Beach".
That's an interesting detail because in the
original book, Chapter 14 leaves the survival
of the Baudelaires unclear, but this implies
that they did make it back to the mainland
because in the TV series we only see the Baudelaires
visit that beach twice.
Once in the very first episode where they
receive the terrible news from Mr Poe that
their parents have died in a fire.
And a second time in the fourth episode of
season 3 when the Baudelaires land in the
Queequeg on Briny Beach where they meet Mr
Poe again, although they ignore him and leave
in Kit's taxi.
I'd like to think that the Baudelaires did
made it back alive, even if they did have
to contend with a set of pirates on the way.
And just maybe, given that Violet learns to
tie a knot from them, those Finnish pirates
actually ended up helping the Baudelaires
on their way back home.
By the way, when the camera pulls back from
the diner for the final shot of the city,
notice the ever-present VFD symbol in the
pattern of the buildings and streets, a little
hint perhaps that the VFD organisation lives
on.
Although Count Olaf really was absolutely
awful to the poor Baudelaires, his deliciously
wicked and hilariously stupid ways certainly
made him entertaining to watch and he was
brilliantly played by Neil Patrick Harris
.
Just like Kit Snicket, Olaf doesn't make it
out of the series alive, however, unlike Kit,
in the end, Olaf died not from the Medusoid
Mycelium, but from the harpoon that Ishmael
shot into his stomach.
A very fascinating detail in both the opera
flashback and the scene on the island is that
Olaf was actually in love with Kit Snicket.
This confirms a suspicion a lot of book readers
had and it also explains some of his indifference
towards his girlfriend Esmé and why he didn't
seem that bothered about breaking up with
her.
Remember, the show did hint at Olaf's feelings
for Kit previously, for example, in Season
2 via the names carved inside a heart.
The other big reveal in the final episode
is that Ishmael is actually the original founder
of VFD.
He started the secret organisation when he
was principal of Prufrock Prep after he spotted
talented pupils with what he calls "a gleam
in their eyes".
For Ishmael, the idea behind VFD was to fight
figurative, not literal, fires, though like
the constantly referenced novel Moby-Dick
where the whale is both a literal whale and
a metaphor for death, the fires that the VFD
ends up involved in turn out to be both literal
and figurative.
Ishmael says he wanted the gifted students
inside VFD to "come together to stand against
the injustice of this world" to make it "a
quieter, safer place", which fits in with
the motto we saw at VFD Headquarters: "The
world is quiet here".
The problem was that the organisation became
divided and split apart in the schism, so
Ish gave up on the world and went to live
in exile on the island.
The supposed paradise that Ishmael established
is like the Garden of Eden.
There's even a tree with special apples on
the other side of the island, a clear allusion
to the Tree of Knowledge and its forbidden
fruit, and a snake also offers an apple to
the Baudelaires, just like Adam and Eve.
Ishmael's appearance also reflects a traditional
ideas of God as a bearded man with long flowing
robes who shields his people from potential
harm.
Ishmael's people all have to eat plain food
with no spices or flavours and when the Baudelaires
discover Ish has been putting drugs in the
coconut cordial, he says "there's nothing
wrong with a little opiate for the people",
echoing how Marx dubbed religion as the "opium
of the people".
A central theme of the show and books is that
many people, especially adults, refuse to
question authority, even in ludicrous situations,
like wearing blindfolds during the trial or
failing to recognise Count Olaf in his crazy
disguises.
Smart characters like the Baudelaires, who
read, educate themselves, question and search
for the truth, are contrasted with foolish
characters like Mr Poe and many others who
refuse to see the reality of what's going
on around them.
The story plays around with the idea of ignorance
as bliss and does so in many ways from the
theme tune's refrain of "look away" to Lemony
Snicket's continued insistence that we stop
watching this dreadful story and do something
more pleasant instead.
It's a clever metaphor for whether it's better
to remain in a state of blissful ignorance
versus the pursuit of knowledge and advancement.
Ish always recommends the islanders discard
anything that washes up on the island for
fear that the object or the technology and
knowledge that it brings might taint the innocence
of the world he's created, in other words,
cause people to question his authority and
create division.
However, he's always keen to point out that
he never forces anyone to do anything, a nod
to mankind's free will, yet the islanders
never do go to the other end of the island
where Ish has been hoarding all the objects
for his own benefit.
Ishmael also knows about the special properties
of the apples in the arboretum and has been
eating them.
Look carefully when the Medusoid Mycelium
is released and you'll notice that Ish is
the only person who doesn't start coughing
and choking.
Even though Ishmael knows there's a cure in
the arboretum, like many religious authorities,
he demands blind faith from the islanders
as he takes them off on an impossible journey
to reach the horseradish factory on Lousy
Lane.
Fortunately for them, the Incredibly Deadly
Viper swims out to their boat with an apple,
suggesting they could have survived and prevented
the disease from spreading to the mainland.
There's so many references packed into this
final episode and the series as a whole that
I'm working on another video about the show
and how it relates to the books.
I'll add a card with the link here and in
the video description as soon as it's ready.
The finale also delivers a few more answers
about the fates of other notable characters
in the series.
The Quagmire triplets' survival is uncertain
in the books, but Chapter 14 of the TV show
tells us that they survived fire and eagles
to be reunited safely.
Fiona's fate in the books was also unclear,
but in the show we see that both she and her
brother Fernald made it through, and end up
reunited with their stepfather Captain Widdershins.
Olaf's troupe, who abandon him after the White-Faced
Women refuse to throw Sunny off Mount Fraught,
also get a pleasant ending in the TV series
as we see they finally get to perform on stage
together "at least for one night".
Now that A Series of Unfortunate Events is
over, how do you feel about how it ended?
And did the show leave any questions unanswered
for you?
Let me know your thoughts and any theories
in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then every week I have
new deep dives into TV shows and movies, so
hit the subscribe button and bell to stay
up-to-date with all my new videos.
Next up, tap left for a new Unfortunate Events
video or tap right for another video you're
sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!